I think young people today and I think
of what we're leaving 10 15 20 years
from now you remind me of that old joke
in the philosophy class where the
professor asked the students which is
worse ignorance ignorance or apathy and
some poor kid from the back of the class
says I don't know and I don't care well
I think it's an interesting question is
there an exciting way that we could get
the young people of this country aware
and their parents because I refuse to
believe that parents have suddenly
become cold and indifferent to their own
kids and grandparents I think they've
been deceived and misinformed and dis
informed and so forth so we have a
political system today for example where
the elderly are unbelievably well
represented the American Association of
Retired Persons as 38 dues-paying
million dues-paying members they write
more they lobby more they call more and
by and large that's not too unfair to
say a lot of their programs are we want
more even though any reasonable standard
as I say some of these challenges are
unsustainable we can't we're not going
to be able to meet the promises that
we've made so on the one hand we have
these this culture of our ethic of
shared sacrifice being kind of a dirty
word not wanting to give up anything we
have political organizations who are
dominant in representing one age group
and the young people who are all about
the future are somehow being slipped
this huge check hidden check I might
for our free lunch and nobody seems to
be doing